county leaders holding an emergency
meeting that's going to happen tomorrow
to talk about ways of addressing the
sharp rise in covid cases here
denise fernand health leaders say
everyone should consider
wearing a mask while in crowded indoor
spaces
it is a recommendation that is not a
mandate joe mohler talked with people
around town to find out if anyone's
behavior is going to change
joe
we're going in a direction that nobody
really wants to go in having to put
these masks back on while
an indoor crowded places out in public
well some people say they're not really
noticing
much of a difference and while others
say they're just noticing a big
difference with employees having to wear
masks well cases are on the rise here in
clark county they're much higher than
they have been the past few months
this pushed the health district to
recommend people to wear these masks
indoors in those crowded areas
now out on the strip some hotels are
making changes for employees to wear
masks
owner of boss security screens in las
vegas is making employees wear a mask
when customers are around
i talked to a few people who were
shopping today at walmart in the
southwest valley they did not notice
much more people wearing the mask i
think it's actually less less people are
actually wearing masks
people are not wearing a mask they don't
care it's just people don't care
i mean i don't know if they're watching
the news or if they're really paying
attention to what's going on
we took this topic to social media and
asked people how they are feeling about
it we first asked that people are using
the mask again indoors
more than 50 percent of people said that
they are we also ask people if they feel
safer knowing that it is recommended to
have these masks on while you're out
indoors and less than half said they
don't feel any different than they did
before the recommendation
reporting live joe moore 8 news now